jubilee media is a youtube phenomenon
from a grassroots start as a simple
production driven by one man trying to
raise money for a good cause to a
million dollar startup revolutionizing
youtube with the real life social
experiment videos that consistently go
viral over and over and over they've
also famously been reacted to by the
likes of pewdiepie codyco and plenty of
other popular streamers and youtubers
and today we get to sit down with jason
lee the founder who started it all and
we chat about the strategies failures
and successes that he has seen in
growing this massive production so if
you guys enjoy videos just like this
make sure to subscribe because we post a
brand new episode every single sunday so
thank you guys so much and now let's
begin the podcast before we go into that
we gotta thank our sponsor ftxus for
those that aware they're one of the
largest us regulated cryptocurrency
exchanges in the world with millions of
users who buy sell track and trade both
nfts and crypto all in one place with
fees that are up to 85 percent lower
than the top competitors what i really
like about them is that they enable you
to set up automatic occurring buys that
you could dollar cost average to the
markets on a regular basis not to
mention the ceo sam bankman freed has
been at the forefront of crypto
regulation and constantly strives to
improve the entire space plus they make
buying and selling extremely simple all
you got to do is select what you want to
buy type in how much you want to buy how
often you want to buy it and then swipe
right and you're done without any
additional work on your end plus they're
coming out with a lot of new amazing
features that you're going to want to be
a part of so if you're interested feel
free to sign up using the link down
below in the description plus real talk
they've helped support us a lot on the
podcast and they're a really great
platform to buy and sell
cryptocurrencies so if you're interested
the link is down below in the
description to get started today thank
you guys so much and now back to the
podcast hello good humans this is jason
wiley from jubilee media with the ice
coffee hour podcast and to date i think
this podcast has made
267 thousand dollars people are getting
pretty close two hundred and fifty one
thousand dollars
that's pretty good you guys haven't
haven't dropped the uh the mr beast or
the the dave ramsey one yet right now
yeah i feel like when that happens it'll
scale quickly those are coming out very
very soon yeah 267 000 okay actually i
think dave ramsey's posting tomorrow or
sunday okay that's coming really soon
hopefully in the next couple of days
then we can get there yeah and then mr
beast probably a week after that so you
might be after these two i don't know
we'll see we'll see we'll figure it out
i feel like i'm in good company actually
yeah you are yeah save me for a good
like being in this stepped up a few
levels of podcast congrats to you guys
thank you so much thank you so much
amazing guests and like having some
really good conversations so yeah well
including you by the way this is
something i've really been looking
forward to this one because i've been
watching jubilee gosh it's been what
five years i am six years old
[Music]
well likewise i was just saying you know
my wife and i we just bought a home but
i was like watching i've seen so many of
your videos but at the time i was like
is this a good time to buy a house and
it's like oh no graham says it's not a
good time
yeah yeah this is the top of the bubble
and then the next video is like it's
never a good time
part of the bubble
and then i'm like okay i don't know uh
but uh
no obviously a big fan and thank you so
much for being a part of a lot of our
stuff at jubilee of course yeah i feel
like you gave me such a huge opportunity
in 2019 i think i was just coming off of
that 78 tesla video and i appeared in a
jubilee video what was it millionaires
versus minimum wage workers
middle ground
yeah and i almost said no to that
episode i had an interview and i didn't
know i didn't know how it was going to
turn out because i watched the video i
think it was uh what was the one where
there was a big argument was it the
vegan versus the yeah there was a odd
one out vegan yeah that was it
they can get kind of spicy and very like
you know it's all about real people
bringing their real stories right we try
to create a safe space for it but
sometimes it can get a little bit heated
so totally i've had friends say like no
i'll never show up on one of your videos
but uh we're happy you came on because i
think you gave such a great like nuanced
view right because people hear about
millionaires and they're like i don't
know like they're all dudes or whatever
and i think that people really resonated
with your story so i mean that's just a
credit to you we're just happy to like
give platform to good people yeah i am
so happy i decided to say yes for that
it was honestly a no up until maybe
a week before maybe 10 days before i was
like you know what what's the worst i
really actually made a pros and cons
list i'm like what if we get in an
argument what if i say something right
because i remember asking one of your
producers i said if i say something
can i have a final say like what gets
put out and they're like no they said no
yeah they said no they just said okay
we'll include what we can we want to
make you look good and we want to make
sure that like you're happy with it but
yeah no we're not going to let you see
it before just be careful of what you're
saying if you need time to speak just
right take your time good that's and i
was like i made a pros and cons list and
i was like there's more pros and cons
i'm gonna do it and i think that video
was like number four on trending it was
it was really well yeah i remember that
and then
am i right that you made a response to
the video too of course yeah any way
possible yeah this is called the
infinite monetization loop yes so if i
could react to my own content i will
right uh because it's just another way
to monetize yeah so later on jubilee i
will have a response to this podcast
yeah perfect these are all the reasons
why this is wrong
um no you've been on several videos now
right three or five four every time our
audience sees you i think that they
really enjoy you and it's awesome to see
you guys blowing up on the podcast and
obviously your videos are always killing
it thank you it's funny because yeah
there was also that video specifically
that sparked my final email to graham
really yeah yes because i was gonna sign
up for it as a minimum wage worker
because i was working minimum wages
imagine if that was yeah how you guys
because i wanted to yeah i forgot about
this yeah and i emailed him about i'm
like dude i'm so bummed out that like i
was gonna sign up and i could have met
you just by chance and i didn't know he
was doing it of course but as soon as i
saw it come out and i was like dang i
was gonna do that one wow yeah it was
been one of our videos i have yeah it
was because of that i think uh was one
of the reasons why jack is now working
with me that's crazy because
unfortunately it was capitalist versus
socialists
and you came in on the
capitol side okay yeah yeah there's been
so many people in our videos that now
people come up to me like hey i was in
your video and i'm always like oh your
face looks so familiar to me but i
didn't think i saw you on the set i
wasn't i i'm rarely on set these days
anymore unfortunately i don't get to be
a part of it as much yeah it would
really be interesting to get an inside
look on like what exactly goes down for
you on a day-to-day basis considering
this is something that you you came up
with it all yourself right i did yeah um
now tell us about this because didn't
you quit your job to
yeah jubilee and create that well i was
watching your podcast with uh was it
elliott who was talking about the
consultants yeah so i'm a former
consultant so i can what do you do
what is that yeah so the way i would
explain it to like my mom for example is
we just help big companies like solve
difficult decisions essentially like
these consultants have seen so many of
the same problems whether it's around
headcount whether it's around strategy
whether it's around like launching a new
product that they're become specialized
at doing that thing and therefore
they're not going to be able to give you
the answer but they can help you answer
a lot of the questions or like ask the
right questions along the way so when he
said like frameworks that's that's the
right answer actually there's like we've
seen this 100 times it doesn't mean now
that you guys are going to launch your
own coffee that we know exactly what
kind of coffee you should launch but we
know all the right questions to ask that
you can avoid some of the pitfalls and
then we would make like a final
recommendation so yeah i was a
consultant for three years so was it a
good gig for me
i grew up in like uh my parents are both
academics so i grew up like pretty
and there were grad students like my
entire life so we're pretty like um
lower income i would say growing up so
growing up i just thought hey one day if
i could make a hundred thousand dollars
as a salary that would be like i'll be
rich that was my mindset
my first job out of college i was making
six figures i was like i've made it so
there was everything i kind of had
dreamed of working in new york city i
was in times square working at bain one
of the biggest consulting firms and i
was like i've made it i'm gonna be so
happy and in a lot of ways it like
checked that box but i think it also
made me really
honestly re-evaluate everything because
i was like i achieved everything i
thought i wanted
and despite all that it wasn't that i
was unhappy but i felt like kind of
unfulfilled
and i think a lot of it was a as it
relates to as a consultant you're
spending so much of your time on your
energy helping other people pursue their
vision or their dreams but you don't get
to own a lot of it yourself and i think
i started to recognize okay maybe i'm
not a
consultant maybe i'm a builder myself
what would that look like if i was doing
that so that was kind of like the whole
whirlwind and it was while i was a
consultant at bain that i made my very
first youtube video and that really
started jubilee project and eventually
jubilee media too gotta tell us about
that video can we see it yeah it's still
dumb
i think that uh yeah if you watch it
it's a little bit like uh cringy to
watch but i think that's important on
the jubilee channel it's still on
jubilee channel yeah so the first video
i ever made was called my hundred for
haiti my 22nd birthday was january 12
2010
but it happened to also be the day of
the haiti earthquake it was just like
weird confluence of events where i just
got in this new job was like living in
new york city new york city apartment
killing it all that and then that
afternoon it was like devastating photos
and videos of haiti and i was like why
am i so blessed what am i doing about
this
and at the time those 2000 and
2009
sorry 2010 is during the height of the
recession so we weren't doing much work
as consultants we were like on the beach
as i said we're just like waiting for
the next case it's like i got to do
something so i decided to go to union
square like a subway stop to busk with
my guitar to raise money we raised
eighty dollars i made my very first
video i put it on youtube i said to all
my friends say hey please watch please
donate and within a week we had
10 000 views we had raised tens of
thousands of dollars and it was kind of
like that light bulb moment not of like
i want to be a youtuber but wow we can
actually use media storytelling to
really galvanize folks and do a lot of
good and that kind of got that started
so soon thereafter i started jubilee
project which was a 501c as a non-profit
i got one of my best friends eric and
one of my and my brother eddie on board
and we were just like doing that rag tag
nights and weekends do you still run as
a non-profit today no we don't okay yeah
so jubilee project still exists as like
a sister organization now like a
foundation to jubilee media and then in
2017 i launched jubilee media which is a
new entity got it and you quit your job
to do that how was that well i quit my
job to do jubilee project
which was insane because this was 2012
and at the time i was working at bain
my older brother eddie was working at
the white house at the time he was at
the obama administration and my friend
eric was at harvard med school
and we were like
doing these videos on the side for fun
and we said you know what this is what
we want to do so we all quit
same day which was crazy it's me and my
brother we're the only children of
korean immigrants eric taiwanese
only child
they're like what are you going to do we
said we're gonna make videos on youtube
they're like how are you gonna make
money and we're like we're not we're
gonna be a non-profit it's like not only
are you gonna be a video creator when
like the idea of being a creator was
still relatively nascent we're gonna do
it as a non-profit so it's like let's
shoot ourselves in both feet so we
cannot walk or run but it was just this
leap of faith you know
i was speaking at an event i don't know
if you ever do like speaking events for
like colleges or things but i was
speaking at an event for college and
there was a woman who had spoke right
before me and she was speaking about a
woman named bonnie ware who's like a
palliative care nurse she's someone who
helps folks who are like on their death
bed
and she asked everyone you know
what is the biggest regret that you have
in your life so
and the biggest regret that folks had
was not like i wish i made more money or
i wish i had traveled more the biggest
regret that folks were about to die
would say was
i wish i had the courage to live a life
true to myself and not one that others
expected of me when i heard that i was
like
cut to the heart i was like oh this is
my life my entire life up until this
point i've made all these decisions
because i was supposed to go to a good
school let me try to go to ivy league
school i was supposed to get a high
paying job and i never asked myself what
is it that i wanted to do and when i
started jubilee project i was like whoa
this is actually feels like something
i'm supposed to do i'm using my gifts my
talent to help other people
i'm going to quit my job and then the
mayhem started right it's like what are
you gonna do my boss is like this is
crazy you have no backup plan we were
making no salary at the time
but it was just like a huge leap of
faith and slowly i saw that like when
you are pursuing what you're meant to do
kind of like the stars in the universe
or god or faith will align to allow you
to help make it so when everyone quit
was the non-profit generating any like
reasonable amount of revenue to quit or
was it just like a hail mary we were
yeah we were bringing in
probably
20 to 30k annually
but all that was going back into our
video content so we weren't actually
making any money ourselves how did you
support yourself then
yeah all of my savings that i had from
vayne i just like used that as my nest
egg and what i mean by like people just
came out and supported us when we moved
to we were going to like move to l.a
right like everyone's here we're moving
to l.a they're like where are you going
to live and eric's mom had said you know
what you can live in our home so they're
like are you going to live we're like
we're going to live in irvine they're
like that's not in l.a um but we lived
in irvine for two years for free my
brother and i we were
23 and probably 25 at that time we were
like living in a bunk bed
you know tiny home finally she kicked us
out someone else that we knew said hey
you can live in my house for free for
another year like all these different
kind of things happens that allowed us
to like just continue to do what we did
that's really generous oh yeah yeah
absolutely and that's the thing it's
like
that's why when folks kind of reach out
to me and say hey i think i'm going to
quit med school i'm going to quit my job
to do this i don't say go for it i say
hey what have you done thus far that can
demonstrate that you'll have some kind
of success right i was doing jubilee
project for several years while at bain
before i quit even but when you start to
make that leap of faith
i kind of truly believe that like things
will kind of
happen and work as long as you're
persistent enough sure and has the style
of content stayed the same
as far as like what you guys are putting
out now versus what you guys were doing
back in the no project days not at all
my first video was my 100 for haiti so
that was kind of like a vlog like
kind of uh video i did several like that
and then we actually started doing like
short films
like romantic skits kind of is what i
would call them i don't know if you're
familiar with wong fu productions
they're big in like the asian american
space but we would do like a love story
but then it would raise money for a
certain cause some of the messaging was
unclear at times but we actually had a
lot of success doing that one of our
biggest videos called blind devotion
short film it's about like seven or
eight minutes ended up getting about
like 25 million views which is unheard
of for like a scripted fictional piece
right so that was really what we were
doing
but then when i started jubilee media i
started to recognize this is like not
really a viable way to scale it cost so
much time and money to do that that we
knew that that's not the way that we
were going to make the difference talk
to us about the evolution between going
from that to where jubilee is today how
many employees do you have we're about
40 employees that's incredible i
remember when i filmed it was a much
bigger operation than i thought i'm used
to just like hey it's it's one person
and like maybe a helper two people like
doing it themselves but it was like a
full-on production it was like a blown
away yeah it's been sometimes when i'm
on set i'm like astounded by what's
happening and i used to direct all of
our videos ourselves and now they're
like please do not touch a camera jason
you're gonna mess something up i'm like
you're right let me stay away um but
yeah the transition from jubilee project
was the three of us it was like the
three of us three musketeers we were
doing this together
but after a couple years both eddie and
eric they fell in love with different
folks and they kind of saw that they had
kind of a different
[Music]
path and they both left and it was just
me doing jubilee project alone actually
did you have to buy them out or did they
just say hey you could take over it was
a non-profit so we had no owner it was
just hey you know sure i'm going to do
something different and actually that
was a really challenging time because
even though we were starting to really
grow in subscribers we had maybe like
150 000 subscribers i want to say we had
just launched blind devotion it got like
20 million views at that time i felt
like a complete failure actually i felt
like my my brother and my friend don't
even believe in what i'm doing i felt
like the last man kind of standing on
like a sinking ship
and that was about a year or two of just
like internal
soul searching i would say where i was
like man what am i supposed to do
i don't know my purpose like is this
even what i'm supposed to be doing
should i go back into consulting should
i go to business school
my mom's like just go to business school
everything will be fine
um
even though that was a really dark and
difficult time it ended up being really
important because i like started to kind
of like pull back all the layers of like
subscriber count didn't not matter to me
anymore like uh getting this person in
the video didn't matter to me anymore
like all these things didn't matter
i started to really ask myself why am i
here what is it that i want to do and on
the back end of that that was
2016 2017 around the election
and after the presidential election it
felt like the world was like more
divided than ever
and that's when i started to see like a
really clear vision for what i wanted to
build jubilee which is as the world's
more divided why don't we create a media
company that's about bringing people
together it's about discourse it's about
provoking understanding and real human
connection and i felt like that was
something that the world really needed
and i was like okay i'm going to try to
do that but this time not as a
non-profit we're going to raise capital
we're going to do this as a proper
venture and we're going to scale this as
large as possible so that kind of kicked
off jubilee media so 2017 i raised a
small round of capital and i was like
off to races who did you raise from well
first i got like i literally have a list
i have 83 no's
so
when you kind of talk about like raising
capital it at first sounds like the most
like
i had no idea what that would even
entail because i had never done that
process i didn't know who to speak to so
i was talking to anyone and everyone and
i actually got into rooms with like
really reputable vcs like a lot a lot of
big investors i totally just blew it
because i had no idea what i was doing
so 83 knows my very first check came
from a professor
at wharton where i went to college who
taught entrepreneurship and she was like
jason
let me kind of help you i believe in
what you're trying to build let me give
you your first check and after that
slowly i started getting checks how much
was the first check my first check i
think it was about 20k okay
and what were you doing wrong to blow it
the first 83 times yeah first of all
articulating the vision
is really really important to tell
people like very clearly what you're
trying to build and why and i think i
knew why i just didn't know how it would
look because at that time you got to
remember there was no middle ground
there was no spectrum there were none of
these shows i was just saying we're
going to make positive content and
people like oh cool like upworthy and i
was like no not like upworthy upworthy
is like what my mom and my grandma
watches i want to make positive content
for young people that will like provoke
them and they're like what do you mean
like buzzfeed i was like no it's going
to be with more value and there's going
to be like a point to it not to say yeah
no [ __ ] to get it yeah
um i think everybody understands yeah
yeah
and then so so many people just didn't
understand it and then secondly
sometimes you find yourself in a room
with someone that will just not say yes
because it's just
not the right fit right like they don't
care about media or they don't invest in
media
they have no interest in what you're
talking about so that was the majority
of the no's
and then once i started to like
articulate what i was trying to build
better and actually get into rooms with
angel investors for example i found oh
they're the folks who are looking
earlier stage like if i'm at a vc
company they're looking to invest big
checks into like slightly further stage
companies whereas angel investors are
like you've got an idea to
make this kind of coffee whatever great
i'll give you 10k 20k but some of our
early angels are like
include everyone from
kevin lynn he's one of the founders of
twitch
steve chen one of the founders of
youtube like we've got some really
incredible founders who some of those
conversations were like the fastest
seven minutes they're like oh cool cool
okay i'll talk to you later i was like
oh i blew it i was like hey is there
anything i can send you to like maybe
give you more info they're like no no
i'm gonna send my check now you know see
part of me believes maybe it's because
you got that first check that all of a
sudden it shifted something for you or
you're like wow the fact that one person
believed in me means that there's got to
be someone else and then that like
changes the mindset too and
think about yourself as an investor do
you want to be the first check yeah
right right like it's a very scary thing
because you're like i've got no
validation but then you start hearing oh
graham and jack both invested and steve
and kevin and the founder of this
company and then you're like oh wait i
want to get in there's like a natural
kind of fomo or human instinct to do
that so it totally makes sense i don't
hold anything against the previous
investors because i think it really
required me to like figure out what i
wanted to build and that process can be
really difficult but it's supposed to
make you a better founder right now was
there a lot of skepticism around youtube
being like a viable profitable business
at the time as well or had it already
kind of proven itself there were
examples luckily at that time buzzfeed
was it was the heyday of buzzfeed where
people were like this yeah what is that
like 2014-ish this was yeah yeah
buzzfeed surveys were everywhere and you
would have to click like a new page for
every single thing like 10 things you
didn't know your girlfriend does that
you have to click eight times i hated
this too and eat all the quizzes and
then the ads at the bottom yeah
everywhere your video content if you
remember like the try guys oh the
trainers are fantastic tasty was just
getting along people were like oh my god
this is the future of entertainment
which
was not untrue right but what people
kind of believe that
media would scale infinitely which we
learned is not the case that you can't
go from 1 000 videos to 2 000 videos and
go to 10 000 videos and believe like
that line will be linear with brand
partnerships for example or with
advertising necessarily because it's
difficult to do but um
there was a model for that and like a
lot of folks were interested still in
that so when someone's an investor does
that mean they get an equity stake in
the company or how does that work it can
look a couple different ways it can come
in the form of like a
debt note or like a safe
so safe is like the yc like the y
combinator version of a debt note
um or it can come as a percentage of
equity but yeah the general idea is this
person is buying a small percentage of
your company and believing that's going
to be worth a lot of money one day and
the interesting thing about angel
investors or like this stage of company
is they really want you to either become
a unicorn like a billion dollar company
or sometimes they would actually rather
you fail like it's not good for them if
you become let's say a
20 million dollar company you're like
making good revenue
you're like
feeding everyone and giving good
salaries to employees because they don't
get an exit actually
right so they want to find the next
facebook yeah microsoft they want their
write-off
yeah if they if they don't fail there's
no write-off that's a good point can't
cancel
that yeah i have to consult
questions later
but yeah so for you personally like
you're kind of i would assume in that
middle there between unicorn and like a
you know struggling i would like to say
that we're right in the middle but
that's not true we're still i think on
the early end generally still in our
life cycle but um it's all a matter of
perspective right
the way i think about it is when you're
first a founder and just yourself and
starting a company it's like going into
the ocean with like
uh inflatable life raft
and you're just like feeling every wave
so every success and this is like so
relevant even to creators too right like
every video that crosses a hundred
thousand or a million views you're like
this is the best thing ever and then you
like
i don't know you have some kind of
problem and it's like the worst problem
and you think oh my company will never
succeed or i'll never be a great creator
and slowly as the company grows
it's not the waves get bigger it's
actually the boat gets bigger so you're
actually able to like withstand some of
that
difficulty better and eventually
hopefully you want to be a unicorn where
you're on a cruise ship right you hit
the same wave you like really don't even
feel it i kind of feel like we are
[Music]
well on our way to being cruise ship but
i still feel like we're still pretty
nimble like i kind of fancy us as like a
small yacht i don't know how do you come
up with some of your ideas like the
originality of your videos i feel like
get copied like you'll come up with the
concept and within a month there's like
five other channels you do the same like
tinder swiping in real life yeah similar
thumbnail styles too yeah like i've seen
i mean they they do they're great
mimickers right it's just sometimes i
see some of their thumbnails like did we
make that no that's not our video oh
interesting i'll watch them like wow
well done um who comes up with those
ideas what was the first big idea was it
was it the swiping in real life the
first big idea no was um was middle
ground okay it's actually the one that
you know you bring two sides together to
quote unquote have a debate but really
it's about finding common ground and
that first idea came about actually this
is pretty interesting there's an
organization called the five ventures
what they do is they'll bring
entrepreneurs or investors and they'll
actually bring them to um
like
federal prisons and you'll spend a
couple of days or weeks with uh
folks in prison who have like an
entrepreneurial idea and at the end of
that program they'll actually pitch and
then they'll like give seed money to
folks who are starting companies
really really incredible and the idea is
like how do we empower folks like have
capital create their own opportunity
right the first day i was in that prison
they had an exercise where they had all
the folks who were incarcerated on one
side they had all the entrepreneurs and
the investors on the other
and they would ask a series of questions
and they would say hey step to the line
if this is true for you i remember some
of the questions were like hey if you
grew up in a two
two
parent household step to the line and
for that one like a lot of folks who are
on my side like step four and some folks
on the other side did not there are
other questions though that were like if
you've ever broken the law before step
to the line and everyone had stepped to
the line right like i've
i've run a red light before i've
done things maybe i'm not proud of and
some things that are just innocuous and
it was very clear that actually a lot of
us had very
a lot in common actually and maybe it
was our circumstances or the way that we
look or different things that actually
cause one of us to be in prison one of
us to be like a founder of a company and
it was just kind of like a very
mind-blowing idea that we actually have
far more in common than we might think
and we started thinking about oh in the
context of his election
i'm from kansas
very very bible about
relatively red state we live in l.a now
relatively or very blue
i know people on both sides of the same
debate who actually have very very
similar interests and actually want the
same thing but they articulate such
different ways and we're like what if it
didn't matter what color shirt you were
and what color shirt i wore but we
talked about like some of these issues
as like humans what kind of things would
we actually agree on and that's kind of
was what really sparked middle ground as
a show
so that's not the way that we come up
with every show we don't go to prison
every time hey just imagine that's the
case
we're out of ideas let's go to prison
today let's see what they're
you're up doing
some of the way we come up
this might be fun um
we really think about
creating new shows as creating ip but we
almost think about it in a startup
perspective
so i don't know if you guys are familiar
with like hackathons and mvps like in
the tech space but hackathon right is
like google will do like a 24-hour
hackathon where they'll be like hey
everyone go and spend 24 hours to build
a
tech product and that's where like
google chats came from or something like
that we said okay what if we actually do
like regular hackathons within our
company so like these used to be 24
hours we don't do it 24 hours anymore
because it's too painful but we'll have
everyone just drop what they're doing
and for a day say hey look what if we
can come up with a thousand video ideas
what would that look like good bad ugly
it doesn't matter
then we'll take a bunch of those ideas
we'll ask a handful of folks to mvp them
mvp standing for a minimum viable
product right it's like what is the
minimum viable thing that you can do to
test whether this idea is a good one or
a bad one
so for example like with spectrum we
actually had one of the guys who came up
with the idea michael go into a room and
he took his iphone and he drove lines on
the ground and said hey i'm going to ask
a series of questions and at the time
there's only three lines and i was like
oh this is not very interesting so he's
like oh let me try out two more lines we
got the five lines he's shot all with
with his iphone and when we watch it
back we're like okay there's something
interesting here so we kind of iterated
on that so before we even like rent a
production space bring on the entire
crew that you see we've thought about
and we've tested to some degree what
that production will look like
and it doesn't mean now it's going to be
100 successful but at least we have like
a process for like weaning out bad ideas
and bad concepts we try to be as
creative on one hand but also as
framework or consulting as possible in
another hand i have to say i really
admire the creativity that goes into
your videos i think middle ground
spectrum uh the ranking attractiveness
intelligence like i would never have
thought of that idea but it's so good
and it's simple and it's easy to watch
anybody could comprehend it and
sometimes people will come some of our
creators will come with an idea i'm like
oh can we do that like you know but i
think that that's a good question that
we want to like be close to that line of
like we really want to make authentic
content that
sometimes provokes people but provokes
understanding for a good purpose yeah
can you say something where you were
presented with an idea and you were like
i don't know that might be crossing the
line
i'll give you a good scenario that i'd
be curious you guys thought on right for
example for us we really want to make
sure that we're trying to be as balanced
as possible so republicans democrats is
the easy one
with vaccines early on those are like a
big debate about you know vaccine
vaccine hesitant there's a question that
always comes up from some of our like
most
empathetic but like hardcore employees
who are like would we ever
feature
white supremacists
in a video and then that kind of becomes
a really interesting and difficult
question so what's the purpose of that
would we be platforming a perspective
that we think could be harmful are we
actually giving empathy but these are
important questions that we have to be
asking ourselves if we want to be
provoking understanding creating human
connection right i feel like from a
business standpoint it's probably not a
good idea because you want to keep like
keep a clean record but i'm a big fan of
just airing out anything right like
letting anybody say whatever and then
obviously i'm a firm believer like
whoever is the most moral whatever the
most ethical argument is will always win
so i'm a fan like you know give whatever
people opportunity to say whatever but i
don't i don't think there's no winning
or losing though i think with something
like middle ground let's say there is no
winner or loser and there there's
i don't know two perspectives and you
let the viewer decide but i don't know
if i would do a middle ground on that
yeah
yeah okay maybe
yeah no it'd be like i'm asking you
yeah yeah right yeah it's more like that
yeah like ask me anything would be
better you know there's not a right
answer to any of them to some degree so
that's where we go back to like what is
our vision our vision at jubilee is we
want to provoke understanding create
human connection what are the values
that we have as a company you know like
in business school when they're like
mission vision values i was like i don't
know why that matters and now i'm like
oh it matters so much to me now because
these are the ways that we're going to
make our decisions and if you ever
disagree with me or with the creative
director or someone who's having to make
one of these decisions there will be a
clear paradigm as to why we've made that
decision that's not just like oh well
graham said he wanted to do that or jack
thought this was a good idea yeah have
you ever filmed something that has not
been aired
like you just couldn't post it all the
time um
we probably don't put out
over ten to
twenty percent of our content really
that seems like a high just because it
wasn't like exciting multiple reasons
one sometimes it's not
of the caliber like it's just not
something that we feel like we're proud
to put out so excellence is one of our
values it's like if it's not excellent
we don't want to put it out
um
we have put out stuff that's not
excellent in the past by the way so um
but that's what we strive for other
times we feel like we've like
inaccurately portrayed or like
insufficiently portrayed one side so for
example if middle ground happens but one
side just like
they're not able to articulate their
points well or personality comes out or
like someone drops out last minute we
get a fill in and we're not feeling like
we've appropriately respected that kind
of point of view then sometimes we'll
just feel like oh it's too imbalanced
well we're gonna have to redo this we'll
have to reshoot this those are probably
the two major examples
the one video idea by the way that
everyone comments on the one that i was
on you gotta get two groups of people
together one self-made millionaires and
one that have inherited their money oh
that's good you've got to do that that
was the top comment i think in a few of
the millionaire videos that you've done
can we have you back for that one yeah
no absolutely i would love to okay we'll
you guys here first we'll we'll start
that yeah i think that comment i've seen
more often than any other comment was
that idea so i gotta represent the
comment section by the way that's right
smash the like button there we go here
we go thank you subscribe
you would probably get a lot of great
ideas honestly just going through the
comments going through every that's what
you should probably have somebody do go
through every single video and just read
the top 20 comments because i read all
the comments and some of the best ideas
come from people just sitting at their
computer this is a good idea and it's
like wow that is a really good idea
that's a great topic yeah we've had some
really good things come that way as well
yeah we have to do a better job now of
just like we get so many just to like
find a way to
to to make it happen but yeah i agree
yeah because they've got a really good
pulse on like what they want to see and
chances are if it's got like 10 000
likes to it then it's like you already
know there's an audience for that
particular topic yep yeah are you ever
worried like you said about you're
putting three people against each other
in a middle ground or something like
that that like you said people people's
arguments can be
poorly portrayed what if you did
something with like 50 people on both
sides and they had like blue and red
shirts and then you could do something
like a spectrum or something like that
where it would lower the variance of how
like one population feels obviously it'd
be a little bit more logistically
challenging
i think it's a great idea uh this idea
of like social polling is one that we've
been toying with quite a bit
um actually the cut
cut
has a great video series that they used
to do called dirty data where they
actually had like a pov camera from the
top and they would have people like move
based on what they believed they stopped
making it i'm not sure why it sounds
expensive it is expensive yeah think
about how many people probably why
yeah yeah but um i think it's a great
idea as far as like you know i think a
lot of times what we don't want to do is
we don't want to say this is fact or
this is fact or this is correct or this
is the correct what we want to be able
to represent is different people's
experiences and beliefs right so it's
not like oh if everyone moves over here
that means that this is right but it's a
great snapshot right now of how people
might think or feel or believe and you
might believe oh this is right but wait
a second everyone moved over here
maybe i'm wrong like when is the last
time we've really heard or seen in media
like
folks kind of take accountability and be
like i don't know like i could be wrong
here or like let me change my
perspective here i think that's like
really important for us to model and
that's something we hope happens within
even middle grounds it doesn't always
happen unless you were like this is my
point i'm sticking to it but what i love
is that coming off of the set there are
so many folks who end up staying in
touch and saying hey i'm still in touch
with
whatever that um gang member i'm still
in touch with that police officer and we
have conversations all the time now
about x y and z so that's like our
mission still kind of at work i think
are you ever worried about someone
signing up for an episode in order to
use that to gain like personal clout or
something like that like kind of like
bad baby did on dr phillips very
strategic where you can act crazy in
order to get publicity from that or
let's say you have like conservatives
versus liberals one liberal or one
conservative could join the other side
right and say that they're the other
person in order to make that population
look crazier i haven't thought about
that second scenario but the first one i
think definitely makes sense and i think
there are a lot of folks who want to be
in our videos just to become famous or
to get clout or followers and
i don't know i mean i don't think that's
a reason we would not have someone in a
video as long as they're like portraying
their
their stance accurately conversely i'm
really proud of the fact that a lot of
people end up having huge careers from
being in our videos for example we had a
guy who was in one of our dating videos
actually it was about like dating 10
musicians based on like their music and
a guy got a record label like he got
signed by really i think i know there
was one guy who's really really really
talented and all the i don't think did
he get picked i don't think he picked he
didn't get picked but why everyone get
picked
it's all about you know it's a personal
choice but yeah people were like this
guy yeah i think i remember that the
amount that he played was actually not
very long and it was incredible but we
saw like we've had that happen we've had
people fall in love and get married and
have no tell us about that
jack you got to get on oh my god
we got some big stuff coming actually
yeah that's something i can share about
this has happened on multiple accounts
actually we've had even fans meet each
other and get married because they just
love jubilee content they're both in our
facebook group they met each other
they're uh they met san francisco and
australia wow long distance they would
watch content together they just became
friends and then now they're married um
so we have crazy stores we've also had
folks like quit their job become
full-time youtubers influencers all that
um so it's been really fun because i
don't know it feels like we get to shine
a light hopefully on good folks who are
like living their life and and pursuing
what they're passionate about now you
have a really interesting uh fiance
story what
did you have you done the wedding yet we
have yeah that's right
i your your invite i there's one video
where you're like oh if i can invite you
to the wedding that's right it was the
reaction to uh millennial money i
remember seeing that yeah we're gonna
talk about that as well but yes uh my
most effective we're married now but i
must have lost the invite it's okay
that's right that's right
yeah yeah whatever i know you were
moving the vegas um
my wife and i okay the way that we met
was
my wife mel she was formerly a reporter
for yahoo finance so she would like just
do a bunch of interviews with ceos and
investors all that stuff and when i was
on facebook one day i was like scrolling
through and literally a ad popped up a
video ad
and you know you usually i'm just like x
out keep scrolling but it was an
interview it was an advertisement for
wealthfront
as an interview with the ceo and it pans
back to the reporter and it's like this
beautiful like brilliant woman asking
all these really good questions i'm like
oh my god she's amazing so i click in i
watch the video think nothing of it next
day i come back the same ad is
kind of fed to me and this happens
multiple times in a row and like hmm
because you clicked it
my mind's like oh my god god wants me to
meet this girl so her name pops up
obviously in the lower third melody hum
i google her i find her on twitter find
out like she's korean american i'm
korean american i'm like ah this is fate
you know she loves like r b she's blah
blah blah turns out she's in new york
but i decided i want to tweet her
um and i just said hey big fan of your
work this is like a public tweet and i
like linked one of the articles hey this
is a great article she was oh thank you
we just become friends on twitter that
was the extent of it
um and because i lived in new york i
would go back every once in a while
actually for a wedding
when i was there i asked her to grab
coffee and she was like okay sure it
ended up being that we end up grabbing
drinks and that night we
spent essentially spend the whole night
walking around new york city uh first
bar we closed at like 3 p.m 3 a.m next
bar close at 5 00 a.m it's crazy bar's
closing fine
the thing i did have to do is catch my
flight in the morning at like 8 a.m so i
remember like the sun was coming up i
was like oh [ __ ] it's worth it man i
haven't packed yeah so i was i was in i
was like this is it she's the one i
never spent a day like that or a first
date like that with anyone so we were
texting and
you know she was like super cool and she
didn't seem like super interested per se
so i was like okay this is on my this is
the ball's in my court if i want to make
something happen so i was in toronto for
a project and i told her oh i have to be
in new york for a week let's like hang
out she was okay sure so i booked a
one-way flight to new york
and i was on my buddy's couch that hey
i'm going to stay here for about a week
or two do you mind oh my god yeah what
about work
well yeah how long ago was this this was
2015 probably oh okay so this was right
around after the guys had left i was
like
no vision for jubilee project i didn't
start jubilee media yeah got it okay
um as soon as i get to new york i'm
texting her hey you want to meet up for
coffee no response
i kid you not three days of no response
i'm like walking around new york i'm
like i'm the stupidest guy ever like i'm
starting like look up flights finally
she's like hey sorry things have been so
busy
we ended up she's like i can meet you
one day for coffee we made up coffee
that went really well i'll make this
short um at that date i was like hey
i've got tickets for a broadway show
tomorrow do you want to come she goes ah
i'll have to move things around but okay
run to the broadway like ticketing
spot tickets smooth and then um at the
end of the week i asked her to be my
girlfriend she said no
uh but a couple of weeks later she said
yeah wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait yeah let's get into that
weeds right here she'll be too soon i'm
guessing right not only that she didn't
want to do long-distance i was in l.a
she was in new york she had done long
distance in the past and she had come
out of a relationship relatively
recently and she was like really just
enjoying her
hot girl summer i think
and i was like i don't know i see it i
see the vision here and she's like i do
not see it but
it ended up she went to a drake concert
like i think had a really good time and
like came home
tipsy and called me and i was like hey
let's do it i was like so
thank you she came back from the concert
thank you drake and she was like wow and
she thought like okay this is this is
the guy now she had a revelation there i
don't know
so that's what you got to do okay if
there's a girl that you really like and
she kind of likes you send her to it
just by yourself
concert what happened what happened at
the drake concert i'm so curious
so now fast forward
start from the bottom now we're here
yeah there you go
six years later yeah we got married uh
during covid so 2020 we had our kind of
covid wedding and then we had like a
real wedding twitter now here's what i'm
curious you asked her dad for his
blessing yeah and he said no wow this is
a deep cut yeah what happened you did
some good research wow
um yeah so mel's father is a maestro in
korea he's like a conductor of an
orchestra amazing brilliant man um
very fiery as you can imagine
and
the day that i asked for permission was
actually her cousin's wedding so mel was
gone she was like with the wedding party
the whole time
um he and i had grabbed lunch earlier
um
and
long story short there's like a series
of events that like went terribly wrong
that like did not go the way i had
planned because i like you know growing
up i was always like the kid that like
parents were like oh he's such a nice
kid like he'll be you know i was just
like not super concerned i was just like
practicing my lines in korean i wanted
to like ask properly we ended up showing
up to a lunch
um that the entire family was supposed
to be a part of but everyone else had to
drop out except for the parents so i was
like oh this is my time
but i ended up being there like in a
t-shirt and shorts and when i asked her
father was like no you
you're obviously not taking this
seriously like why are you dressed this
way you should be in a suit if you're
going to ask me for my permission it
should be way more formal so that was
like the start of a terrible day
later what happens is we decide that
we're gonna go to the wedding together
from the hotel
i run down my suit
super early i'm like five minutes five
ten minutes early as soon as i sit down
i have like a small tear in my pants i'm
like [ __ ] he's he's gonna be the one
type of person who will see it like dude
this guy's a scrub like what's going on
so i run to the front desk i was like
hey do you have a sewing kit they're
like yeah we do i'm like perfect run to
the bathroom like sew it up get a call
in my room they're like where are you i
look at the clock i'm like three minutes
late i'm like shoot come back down get
in the car and he's like why are you
late
clearly you're irresponsible he said
that you're lazy i don't like you for my
daughter yeah
and i was like ah and i was like oh
sorry i forgot my card he goes no that's
not acceptable get out of my car no
and i was like no sorry and then i said
okay the truth is i just tear in my
pants so all right fine so we're going
driving driving driving mom's in the
back seat i'm in the front seat you know
i'm like navigating for him
new jersey highways is like very rural
was your girlfriend your girlfriend was
not in the car no she was at the wedding
slowly he's getting more and more angry
he's kind of saying like oh in my family
this is not okay i don't like you
blah blah like this this and this reason
you show up to lunch like super
underdressed then you like are late i
don't like this it got to the point that
i started getting really upset because i
just felt like i was getting berated so
i very calmly said
i totally understand i'm so sorry but in
my family like we don't talk to each
other this way and when i said that
opened the door and he kicked me out and
left me on the side of the highway and
left me yeah are you serious so i ended
up ubering to the wedding
that became a whole thing right because
then it was like
i was like preparing to buy to get the
ring
i knew how i wanted to ask mel to get
married but it's it kind of caused like
a good series of conversations with
myself and with her first of all about
like if we're to be in a family what are
we going to be like you know ask a lot
of difficult questions me talking with
my parents her talking with her parents
eventually
eventually i said you know what i'm
going to ask her and lo and behold like
her dad has come around like two-fold
and it's amazing and it's like what's so
happening so what was the conversation
you had with your girlfriend at the time
did you tell her about these
conversations be like yeah yeah she did
yeah oh she knew about it he probably
did he tell her she oh no she died
afterwards no
in fact she was like oh i've
you know he's an incredible person but
he's um very i would say like he's
pretty idiosyncratic like his
personality type so every time she would
tell me about him i didn't really
understand but then i experienced it
myself and it actually gave me a
tremendous amount of empathy for for
like her and what her upbringing was so
a lot of ways i think it was like very
um
positive actually in retrospect okay was
she okay getting married without her
dad's permission or did you wait then
until you got her dad's permission and
then he proposed you know once i
proposed and she said yes her dad was
like oh i'm so excited and at the
wedding his speech was the best because
he essentially says you know all this
time i this is my only daughter her
their only child yeah i was this is a
series of tests i wanted to put you
through and jason you've won is what he
said at the end of his speech do you
think they were tests
he's
he's awesome now so we get along really
well
i'll tell you the first time i met him
this was far before the lunch
i literally i meet him and he's like hey
i'm a big soccer fan are you a big
soccer fan i go oh you know i watch but
i don't really play he goes let's go to
the field and we'll like play some
soccer i go oh cool like just the two of
these guys yeah
he shows up he's got clitza and he's got
like uh goalie gloves i go oh we're
gonna play soccer soccer he goes yeah
and he goes we're going to do a series
of um penalty kicks
and if i beat you you can't date my
daughter anymore oh
and i'm like oh my god you know this guy
he's like pulling out he's prepared
so and mel was there she's just laughing
she thinks it's hilarious i get down
four to one
um in the series
so we're doing the five i'm down four
series four to one i'm like crap like if
i lose five's a one i'm like this is bad
bad i came back 4-4
he ends up beating me 5-4 but he's like
you know what i see a lot of resilience
in you good job you can still keep
dating like this is obviously a joke
could be a good test though if you make
it so unbearable for the boyfriend that
if he leaves you know he's not one to
stick around yeah but if he does it
anyway and he and he perseveres then
he's someone who will work through those
issues if you have a daughter would you
put her i don't have your boyfriend
through any tests i don't know how i
would be out what's your
i feel like i would play a lot of jokes
you know just like make it make it just
like unbearable the credit card
statement would come up yeah i see
you're spending seven dollars
how much do you think it would cost you
to make your own costs
yeah did you guys buy a house yet we did
yeah we bought a house we bought a house
um when was this that we closed probably
in
march or april
south l.a but yeah can you tell us like
the city yeah we're like near lamar park
okay like west of usc yeah well i know
you're in vegas now yeah how has that
been it's it's really nice i honestly i
i have never imagined that i would live
there to be like if you told me three or
four years ago never would have thought
i'd want to live in vegas
until i found
like two really nice communities both
henderson and summerlin are fantastic
and everyone is so friendly it's one of
the few places where i could be like
walking down the street and like
someone's driving but i don't even know
this anybody uh drive by but they'll
just wave you'll say hi
i'll say hi back everyone is so friendly
you see the same people at the community
gym at the same times they're always
there it's like it's a really nice
friendly place and i think it's because
you get people from around the country
that maybe are from areas where they're
more open the reason i ask is that i
think community is so important yeah
like who do you surround yourself with
especially as creators when like you
have to be able to find a place to go
back to the well and when you feel like
dry creatively i think you need to find
folks who are not even doing the same
type of content or some same type of
business but they're excited about what
they're doing and that can get kind of
give you inspiration or like help kind
of fill your tank so to speak yeah i had
a pretty terrible neighbor at uh west
adams yeah she was older yeah she was
the lady who's been there for probably
50 to 60 years and i went over to
introduce myself and i remember i
brought her a bottle of wine i i think i
got her some like some snacks and i
really wanted to make good with the
neighbors because i was remodeling that
house and i was probably gonna spend
like five six months fixing it up
i didn't want there to be any you know
any animosity and i will never afraid
one of the first things she told me is
make sure you you don't put your trash
cans out front of my place you got to
put your trash cans in on this side not
in front of it and she went off because
i guess the person who lived there
before would put the trash cans like in
the driveway it was kind of like on her
side and she wanted to make very clear
that my trash cans went in front of mine
and not hers right and since then it has
been a struggle like i never want to do
anything to provoke her but like
sometimes i'll do anything and she'll
just flip off like um there was a time
where i forget what it was it's in the
backyard doing something and so she
purposely took water and started
spraying my car i forget what it was
what were you doing i don't know what i
was doing
no i no i'm so quiet i forget what it
was
worse yeah now the worst was that i had
a driveway where it was basically my
driveway and then right next was her uh
front yard so
i mean maybe there's like a foot in
between my car and her front yard and i
had a service technician come to do like
an inspection of my car before i
returned it as a lease
and the guy was kind of like standing on
her side of the yard and she comes out
and turns on the sprinklers no
yeah gets him soaking wet yeah and he
had his ipad laying down there for like
you know for the for the car company and
just sprays all of us and we're telling
her like hey we're just out here like
we're not being noisy nothing didn't
care to turn on the sprinklers uh
there's been so many instances where she
has just been so just awful she's
screamed at us before oh there was one
time too it was raining
right before like right when covid was
announced and we were moving some stuff
in the rain 8 p.m at night and she
complained that we were being too loud
in the driveway and it was literally
just closing doors and stuff like that
in the rain it's horrible the thing
about neighbors is like when you have a
bad neighbor it can just like ruin
everything about your living experience
i'm curious what are your thoughts on
like what is the premium or depreciation
of an asset based on like how good of a
neighbor is would you say like how much
weight the thing is i don't feel like it
it makes the value of the property go up
like a good neighbors yeah worth more
but it you can certainly negatively
impact it because you got to think too
while you're selling imagine a
prospective buyer like parks in front of
her house right and she comes out and
yells at that person right it's over
right so yeah there was a house at the
bottom of the street that i grew up in
and they were or there was a lot and
they were building these two really tall
homes right next to each other and
across the street there was a small
single story house and they put up
probably like a
12 foot by five foot uh like board and
spray painted on if you buy these houses
you'll see us naked in our bathroom
through a glass window they did that to
try to deter prospective buyers from the
house ended up being a selling point
though for months did someone in their
minds obviously yeah
yeah and that's it dude that's so
stressful yeah
[Music]
i don't know something about buying a
home i think that like a lot of like
human instinct come out in good and bad
ways i find that i'm becoming like a lot
like my dad like i walk around like
putzing around in the yard or like
i just love grilling now i don't know
i'm like oh i love me but there's
something also just about like i own
this land and therefore
i don't know
it makes me bummed when i see that
version of it whereas i think there's a
beautiful version of it where i've seen
a lot of my friends who've won homes who
are like this is a space i want to build
community in right or like we try to
have like you know dinner parties at our
place we're like hey come on over like
we're gonna cook for everyone
we can finally do that because we have a
home so um i'm bummed to hear that
though is everything okay do you have
tenants at the house yes unfortunately
okay they're fine they've never
mentioned it nothing no i mean i i think
they they follow some of her rules like
for the trash
things like that but yeah thankfully the
tenants who are there now are amazing i
really really like them a lot yeah
that's good that's good small chance
they're watching this i don't think so
and to the woman as well it's like hey
we're just sending you love we'll make
sure we take care of the trash no
worries
speaking of love you were mentioning
love
um
well actually what is your what is your
relationship status where are you i'm
single it's complicated
okay i'm really single how are you
finding love life in vegas versus la i
don't know if there's much of a
difference i think in vegas there's a
lot more people coming and going yeah
whereas la there's a lot more people
living there
um
in l.a honestly i didn't really
i didn't like go on many dates you know
what i mean because like i was very busy
at that period of time in my life
whereas now you know i can go on dates
but i still don't necessarily go on a
lot of dates are you are you on the apps
yeah oh all of them yeah yeah i only
asked because we've been doing a big
deep dive in like the love space for
young people and what we're finding is
that like
something like 50 million americans are
on dating apps
but the mps score like the net promoter
score for the dating app industry is -25
meaning the majority of folks who are on
apps are very disgruntled with their app
experience
they're finding and when we do these
interviews they're finding that i'm
spending a lot of time on the app a lot
of times these won't necessarily
translate into real in-person dates or i
spend like it's not the proper roi or
whatever it's like swiping culture like
a little fatigue of it so they're not
getting dates that's the problem
they're not getting dates or they feel
like maybe this is not even the right
way to even
look who is is that both male and female
um i think that we're seeing a little
actually both yeah relatively both okay
um because i i've heard somewhere that i
think it's the top five percent of
profiles were matched with the vast
majority yes there is yeah and you might
be part of this you're a good-looking
guy so i feel like you might be
in that group that's like hey i'm having
a great time but i think the majority of
folks are feeling like oh [ __ ] like this
kind of sucks the reason i ask that
though is because we're actually i don't
know when this podcast will come out but
september 20th we're launching a new
brand a whole new channel
all around love
so all of our dating content is going to
go there and we're actually starting to
build even um
technology and like different things
that's going to are you going to create
your own dating app maybe eventually
that could be where we would wow now how
do you differentiate because i feel like
dating apps are a lot like a good title
thumbnail where you really gotta hone in
you can't just create
you know throw up a picture and expect
people to to match with you i feel like
most people are really bad at describing
themselves yes and conveying who they
are we completely agree yeah i know are
you guys um
fans of like enneagram or myers-briggs
like uh i've heard of the myers-briggs
like horoscope right or sure
all of these tools that we use to like
self-categorize ourselves into
personality
i'm an extrovert i'm an introvert i'm
like a thinker versus a feeler right and
what we found was that like with
relationship stuff there's a lot of
different personality types or even
relationship beliefs but there's no good
way to categorize them there is like
love languages like i love gifts or acts
of service but that's not
what leads to compatibility but what
we've been working
on behind the scenes i guess this is
relatively public if i share this but um
is we've been working with a bunch of
data scientists and like relationship
scientists on what are actual
relationship beliefs that we have so for
example one of the criteria is like a
are you an i person or a we person right
and some people are i people even if i'm
in a relationship with my wife i may
still go somewhere and i don't expect
her to come and i'm not even wanting her
to come sometimes we're independent
people you do your thing i do your thing
we're still partners but we're i people
some people are we people right you know
every time they show up they're going to
show up with their partner and that's
not good or bad the problem sometimes
happens when there's an eye person with
a we person not that they're less
compatible but they have to have that
conversation
i
yeah and your partner uh i would say
yeah yeah she's a woman so you you have
to have a conversation right about like
what does that look like for you to be
able to like does that change yeah i
feel like there's a bit of a give and
take yeah you know exactly she gives all
wait no
let's say we each have to give and take
i mean you know what i mean yeah you
know
there's a balancing act
so what we're trying to build is
actually um
almost like a personality or a love
assessment that we can all take and just
kind of identify
am i an i person or a we person am i
like intimacy am i more physical or am i
more emotional none of these are better
or worse but it's better to understand
ourselves yeah because we actually
um might fit better initially with
someone who are more similar so does it
give you like a score like oh it's 85
compatible or something like that we're
actually not even starting with
compatibility we're starting with
individual assessment so you'll get like
a your own kind of like readout on hey
this is who you are oh interesting so
people will take a quiz then they'll
it'll spit back some information yeah
they'll be like you're a magenta and
this is why and this is what you should
be looking for and this is what you
should be thinking about so you give
them some tools but you don't match them
based on that eventually we'll go into
matching but we want to start with we
actually think that the not the problem
but one of the things that's broken with
dating culture is that people are not
even
critically thinking about who they are
in a relationship or what they want in a
relationship
so if we can kind of give some of those
tools
via the technology and via our content
eventually that we can actually lead to
better compatibility too
so imagine if you're a magenta and i'm a
magenta like we might be more compatible
initially right so like that could be
good
um or at least it'll give us good
framework to like have that conversation
of like hey jack i know that you said
that you're like a physical intimacy
person but i'm more emotional person so
i need more time where we talk about
stuff before we make out whatever
there's a hypothetical by the way um but
yeah we're excited to launch all this
it's gonna it's called nectar the whole
space and we're gonna launch it in a
couple called nectar next one nectar
it's a decent name yeah i think it's
fine that's good i'm happy you didn't
say oh that's a terrible yeah
um
i kind of think like love is like the
like the essence of life right it's like
the magic of life and life we can like
distill that down and like purify it
like that's how we kind of think about
nectar are you gonna also do that for
friends yeah i think relationships when
we say relationships um it shouldn't
just be about uh romantic relationships
but i think initially most of our
content is all going to be around like
love content so i think people will
initially think about the assessment as
a loved one are you taking investors
we actually just raised another small
round of comments do you actually yeah i
don't know if you're serious again i'm
serious yeah we can talk about it
separately yeah um because i think all
the content would revolve like at the
end of the day
nectar
so it seems like a lot of organic reach
that you've already built exactly if you
remember we did a whole
we did a middle ground and we did a
partnership with the ground called
ground news and they're like a news
aggregating website but you can read any
article and they'll tell you like hey
this article leans like 73 conservative
or this article is like skewing 82
percent liberal and we worked with them
to build a custom test like a news bias
test where anyone could take it takes 15
minutes
and it'll tell you what your score is
but in the episode of every video it
popped up it was like hey this is jack
he's 23. he's 72 percent liberal or his
uh news bias is 72 percent liberal et
cetera
we plugged it into the video the video
did relatively well maybe a million
million have views within a week we had
120 000 users of the test
wow
zero
customer acquisition cost zero cac what
if now we're building our own product
and technology that fits into what
people are interested in anyways around
love
politics identity that's been the whole
vision of what jubilee is going to
become we love making the media content
but what young people keep on wanting to
do is they want to like participate they
want to be in the videos obviously but
what is we can't do that we can't put
everyone in the videos what if we can
actually build
deeper ways for people to engage and
actually participate in other ways
love is a great way to do that you can
imagine you know dating events dating
apps yeah i'm gonna imagine going back
into politics political compass
conversations all that stuff how would
it make money
dating is actually incredibly lucrative
um 50 of tinder users are paying
so that's yeah oh yeah you find more
success there it's been a long time
since i've been dating uh i would say i
find more success yeah if i'm because i
could i can like sort by like for
example people that like me i can see
exactly who they are rather than just
continually and it's like not that much
right per month it's well i have the
i've got that you know that okay let's
get the premium version let's go well
hey uh this is good and that's uh i
don't know i think it's like 90 bucks
per
per
six months or something like that i
thought you were about to save money
oh my god
he's a finance youtuber one of the big
ones he sold me on it because he said
jack if you're spending let's say
theoretically
an hour per day doing that whereas you
could now be spending 10 minutes per day
it's you know no i think that that
totally makes sense yeah yeah and that's
what i'm saying about there's a problem
right now because people are spending
hours on dating apps with very low
yields don't they want that though isn't
it good for tinder because i saw an
article somewhere absolutely
yeah that tinder is programmed to keep
you on the app as long as possible
absolutely because there's always that
like next like hit but there's a problem
really it's the same thing with tick
tock it's like not every video is right
right no i mean it's like they took
after the casino uh logic there where
you don't want to do everyone but you
want to keep it like staggered to keep
your brain always like on edge like
where's the next video tinder i think is
probably similar but what if we could up
end the entire paradigm as to which even
dating apps exist that's no longer even
about swipe culture but there is some
sort of compatibility component or even
interaction that's not just like hey
what's up we've built a series of
different ways that humans can interact
through our shows that are fun and
entertaining and interesting that's like
takes pressure off we find like there
can be all these different ways that
people actually engage and like no
pressure like we're going to play the
game or we're going to like
answer the series of questions in an
interesting way so we've had a lot of
excitement about that so we raised a
small round from mostly tech investors
because the one thing we haven't done
well before is we've never built
anything tech based so
um it's probably going to be way more
expensive than you think it takes way
longer yeah so we're going to kind of
try to
how do we mvp this as well right meaning
how do we actually show traction
and gain a lot of users without doing
the full thing
there's a way to kind of do it in a
low-fi way yeah that's going to be a
bigger part of the approach that's
exciting and what's your end goal with
that like let's say you build it up and
it is successful it's working
what if jubilee could be the home for
all human connection full stop we grew
up in a time where like facebook is all
about social connection and making
friends but the truth is we're not
making friends on facebook we're not
really even making friends on instagram
it's not built for that what i think is
happening right now is that young people
in particular gen z
even though they're more connected than
never they're actually more lonely than
ever
and what we want to do is we want to
find ways through our content to bring
people together but now through
technology do that too and maybe even
one day in person like we actually right
before kovid were starting to do
something called um
the empathy warehouse
where we would have different rooms and
every room would be like
pretty intense like social experiment
that you're kind of like oh [ __ ] we're
going to do this but it created this
incredible like you know that kismet
feeling when you're like on the subway
or you meet someone you're like man that
was like such a cool
conversation
i think that we're just longing for that
and we need that i think that there's a
way for us to create spaces for that to
happen so that's kind of the big vision
of jubilee that's why as we think about
becoming that cruise ship or that you
know that unicorn that's what we would
have to become
but we feel like we're kind of like well
on our way towards that that's really
cool yeah appreciate it are there any
video ideas that you've wanted to do you
just don't have the funding to do it oh
maybe it's just too expensive uh i
really like that show on netflix love is
blind yeah i loved that show love is
blind it's good love on the spectrum is
good oh my gosh we macy and i watched i
think all three seasons it's one of the
it was it is the most heartwarming show
yeah you kind of see that and you see
like oh there's a way to do reality
television in a way that's actually like
meaningful yeah without being terrible
um or corny sorry what are these shows
oh love on the spectrum if you did a
version of love on the spectrum oh my
gosh so they they had people pair up uh
that are on the autism spectrum ranging
from you know severe to you know high
functioning mild
and they follow their stories their
interests and their complications with
dating and i think what makes it so
relatable is that everyone i feel like
has had those experiences where you walk
up like you're nervous and the guy's
literally looking at the camera like i
don't have to show it i don't have
anything to talk about anymore
i don't know what to say
and they come back and they're just like
so the weather is nice they're like yep
and it's silenced but i think everyone
just understands that but it's but it's
heartwarming because it's so genuine
yeah and um they're so open with how
they feel even though it might be
difficult for them to talk about that
it's really you gotta watch it okay it's
one of the few shows where you feel
better after watching it
god it's weird to describe but it's it's
it's just hard like you feel
good after watching it's like it's
really nice
and you've seen the other one i love
this guy i haven't even heard of that
it's where individuals will first meet
and they'll actually like fall in love
without ever seeing each other and then
they'll like choose an individual and
even like propose to each other having
never seen each other so like is love
really blind is like kind of the house
how do they make it happen they're in
like pods that are like you can see
silhouette but you can't actually see
individuals yeah but they're doing over
the course of like weeks or days or and
then they marry each other afterwards
they have to propose to meet each other
holy mackerel so the gimmick is pretty
pretty what do you think the divorce
rate is
not that much
i think the success rate was pretty low
actually yeah
so i don't know yeah some of the couples
they they followed up with and i'm like
that is a train wreck relationship
it really they seem so unhappy but they
stay together maybe because of the show
yeah because because they gave contracts
they've gained no no but they've gained
so much popularity as a couple right
that they've turned into they're all
influencers now wow all of them i mean
you can't work a normal job and then be
on love is blind one of the hit netflix
reality tv show you get millions of
followers and be like well i'm gonna
still work at my job for you know 80
grand a year right you're gonna make a
million dollars a year just being an
influencer but yeah doing uh doing an
episodic dating show is something we've
been really interested in so that's
something that we've been toying with
and doing it the right way the problem
with a lot of existing reality shows is
like if you look at the behind the
scenes of like what the producers are
making individuals do it's like so
gnarly for example there's a show called
um have you heard of the ultimatum no
it's like graham and i are in
relationship
i want to get married but graham's never
going to propose to me we're going to go
on the show and either he's going to
propose to me or we're going to break up
and we're going to switch partners with
someone else
so i'm going to choose someone else for
six weeks and at the end of that either
i will choose to marry this person or
i'm gonna marry graham or he's gonna
decide oh my god but apparently what
they did what the producers did was when
they signed up for the show they didn't
know that there was an ultimatum even
involved oh and they said you guys like
and as they were starting to film they
were like you guys have to have an
ultimatum graham is the one who does not
want to get married jason you're the one
who wants to get married so you know
what i mean like they're put into this
scenario in such a false way that you're
like well the whole premise
it's all flawed then right if this is
all a charade like no one's coming into
this like with real authentic and then
and then everything falls apart in my in
my point of view but
i think that we can make great shows
like i don't know if you guys have seen
a terrace house
no it's a show that started in japan but
it's like so raw authentic like it feels
like no production is touching it just
like living their life and so it's done
in such a beautiful way that became
really popular but um speaking of
reality tv shows i feel like i've seen
you uh in a couple of episodes of
something like sunset i didn't i i i
don't think i had pieced together what
happened but what was the back story
there are you working
in the show or no
no so when they approached jason i
forget exactly how it went down but uh
they filmed a pilot okay and i was in
the pilot episode of the first season of
the first season and they cut me out
pretty quick uh
i think there are two things drama yeah
there were two things that happened i
think uh they wanted me to fill that
spot of drama of like what do you think
of christine they were they would ask me
questions of like each person i worked
with what do you think of heather
heather's great i like her a lot what do
you think of christine she's awesome
mary's are really hard like i i didn't
say anything negative about anybody yeah
uh and also i knew that they would see
this so it's not like why would i say
anything bad about anybody if they're
gonna tell that they wanted you to say
oh 100 would they even lead you towards
that or not uh a little bit they would
uh
they would say so you know do you go to
clubs a lot how do you spend your money
are you flashy like things like this
where i think they wanted me to become
like this playboy who clubs every night
who's dissing on everyone i'm working
with and like living that sort of
lifestyle right i couldn't do that i
mean that's not me and so they made it
pretty quick that they i was cut out of
that but then i think they realized the
dynamic between
the you know the women in the office
was way more interesting to focus on
that than yeah me i mean i'm not gonna
say anything bad uh and that was around
the time too where um the youtube
channel was beginning to actually gain
some traction i think maybe i had 20 000
subscribers at the time and i remember
kind of thinking between the two like
what if they asked me to be on it like
would i give up the channel i was like
no i wouldn't give up the channel were
you you were working with the group
though prior to the show even starting
yeah yeah so i joined the oppenheim
group i think 2014 or 15 i can't
remember okay and you're still with them
uh no so when i left california i also
left the brokerage
great episode though you walk in you're
like jason i'm done i'm moving to vegas
yeah well i mean it happened organically
um
i would i would still be in the office
five days a week but as the channel
began doing better and better and better
i just slowly you know stopped taking
out as many clients if there's a client
that would take a lot of time i'd pass
them off to someone else in the office i
slowly scaled back so it was never like
an abrupt stop but yeah when when covet
hit was the time where like nobody was
doing any showings open houses stopped
entirely and when you're home i'm like
well i'm gonna just make youtube videos
this is right
i'm gonna go 100 in this and then pretty
quickly i realize like wow this is what
i want to do there was one scene it was
the first season
um
where
i saw all the cameras pointed in one
direction i'm like i'm gonna sit there
because because i i felt like i got no
screen time so i'm like i'm gonna sit
right there and it turned out that was
the where like some drama went down i'm
just you just see me sitting there i
just kind of like observing i had no
idea what was going on i had no idea
what anything was about but i yeah
that's what i was able to get there yeah
insane though huh like there's so many
people who watch selling sunset yeah you
know it's crazy we had no idea how
successful that was going to be and i
remember the first season that came out
it got kind of mixed reviews the very
beginning
some people really disliked it they
thought it was in poor taste other
people really loved it
um i think when season two and three
came out was when it really started to
shine and i think because just everyone
who was being filmed all the cast just
got more comfortable being around
cameras like being filmed and i think i
mean maybe i'm sp i shouldn't be
speaking for them i'm guessing maybe
they let their guard down a little bit
more yeah um season two three and four
that people got a real sense of like
who they are and what they're about how
do you feel about the portrayal of the
different characters do you feel like
it's pretty appropriate fair yes i mean
i guess the only thing that i think is
that they film i've seen how much they
film and so you can only show so much
in i don't know eight one hour episodes
but they'll be filming for months right
and so you take months of stuff and
condense it down to like the moments
that are the best like the the highlight
and it resonates with their character as
like this type of person right so for
all of us i'm sure like over a month we
have one hour of highlights that are
just like the best that make it seem so
exciting but when you add in all the
other stuff like you could just as
easily edit it down to be like i do
nothing but stay home and watch youtube
videos or wow i'm traveling every day
it's so crazy right so you could
probably narrate whatever direction and
it's up to them but they got to do
something that people want to watch
unscripted space which folks would call
us in the unscripted space but the way
that they approach content can be
radically different too so we've seen
some like bad actors and we've seen some
like amazing people and we're trying
like you know how do you navigate both
creating something that's
entertaining the watch but is also
authentic or real like that can be a
really difficult challenge
i wanted to ask you what your experience
with millennial money was because i know
that's something we both were a part of
but that's right because i did i did
mine did i do mine before yours or after
i think
after years yeah well i have i had two
millennial monies the the first one
okay yeah the first one was fantastic it
was when jessica
was in charge of that and she was
meticulous i mean yeah you could tell
when somebody is so sharp and like on it
and she was that person she was the one
asking the difficult question yes well
she was just her vision her shots what
she wanted was so clear and good it was
like so aligned with exactly what i
believed should be done and
my experience with her was a 10 out of
10.
and she was responsible for all the
early millennial monies
and you could tell all of those were
just like hit after hit after hit after
that the second one i felt um i wished
it had her attention to detail on it and
she had temporarily stepped back because
she had a child
and so i had a good experience but
nowhere near the level that i had with
jessica what was the difference between
the first and second as far as just the
angle oh man it was um i mean the shots
yeah it was kind of a wrong question it
was kind of around the cove at times so
i think they they hired out some of the
people and they were contractors
and it just was it didn't hit and there
were a lot of suggestions that i wanted
to do but i didn't want to get in their
way right but then i saw the shot like
that's a terrible shot the lighting is
awful yeah um
i didn't like the angle that they took
with it um but then again nothing is
ever as magical as the first time you do
it so it's like how do you live up to
that i would never expect to surpass
that first one it was so good i only
asked because i find that the millennial
money audience is like very strong like
i'm just i i wasn't super familiar with
i had seen several but i didn't realize
that people just love watching these
millennial monies like understanding how
people use their money and how people
make their money when i first been
approached to do it similar to you with
jubilee i was like i i don't know why i
would do that i'm not sure like why
would i show my finances i was like this
feels very deeply personal and then
later i was like oh actually this would
be really um an interesting exercise
just to show even my team like
how much money does jason make right
like how did how is this money spent
even so yeah i had an interesting uh
intro with them yeah so i was introduced
to them because i was reacting to their
videos they would post a video i
remember that and then two days later my
reaction would post on their video
and in the in
well for a lot of those videos my
reactions would get more views than
their videos were
and so i did this for months and that's
really how i grew that second channel
was just off of them
and
you know
i don't know i got an email from them
and i remembered like oh my god they
just emailed me this is crazy and i got
on a call and
i don't know if i was speaking with
jessica i think i may have been but she
was saying so do you intend to keep
going with these uh videos and i'm like
yeah they're doing really well there's
something like oh yeah i guess that's
the youtube thing to do like i don't
think she was exactly happy that i was
right because you could tell and i could
tell too she poured her heart and soul
into these videos
and to have me come on and like
take
views from that and then add
silly commentary about the
spending i don't think because for her i
think it was like it was a piece of art
that she was creating and i see that
vision right and it's like what's up you
guys welcome back to the show let's see
what this is you know it's just i don't
wanna say poking fun at it but it was
definitely taking a very light-hearted
approach to something that she took very
seriously and i understood that and then
she asked if i wanted to be on it i was
like i can't say no but you didn't want
to i you were like really 50 50 yeah the
reason why was because
i felt like they would do something
because i was yeah like
and they're gonna be like we'll get back
at graham for this
uh for you know reacting to our videos
and doing all the
so and and i mean
because i was really into seo like i
wanted to rank on millennial money yeah
and so all of mine would have millennial
money in the title so when you typed in
millennial money like my videos came up
first before theirs
and so it's like all these
silly tricks but you know i wanted to
rank first i thought it was entertaining
content i enjoyed it i was happy to talk
about it i felt like
you know they would have all my info and
they could spin it would it like similar
to
netflix or with jubilee 2 like you could
they could edit in whatever the way they
wanted of course i didn't want to be
portrayed as like maybe someone who was
you know i i don't know
just
after that did you continue do you
continue are you still doing the
millennial money reaction yes
not too much not as much well my
experience was with filming them was
fantastic when i saw the episode they
showed it to me the night before i loved
it yeah and they did such a fantastic
job and then after that i'm like
anything i could help jessica with it i
mean i'm forever grateful for them um
i don't know if they do
i see i'm probably too uh too arrogant
to think that like they did this because
of me but all the videos became too
positive and not that good to react to
after a while like that yeah yeah and
everyone has a youtube channel it's like
a joke of now coming on it's like oh
guess what they got a youtube channel
and it just became not as fun like the
beginning episodes were so good because
uh
sometimes i felt like the people were so
bad with their money right and that's
what kind of made it enjoyable they were
making a lot they were spending a lot
and the expenses were so out there but
now it's like went to college without
any debt uh joined the military started
the youtube channel
right yeah i think it's like i i can't
say a single negative thing about the
people who are on now yeah and it makes
it less fun to react to just because
there's nothing i could poke at there's
nothing they're doing wrong everything
is perfect there's only so many times i
can say hey
this person is perfect great example
keep doing your thing well this is why i
i've always felt and i think we've
talked about it you talked with folks on
my team about it like you would be such
a good host for that kind of a show
that like what you're doing like um
that's right you know what yeah yeah my
finances kind of thing i remember you
guys reached out a while ago to make
that happen yeah i think that there's
such a avenue for it not only because
it's entertaining because it is but
there's a lot of financial education
that happens that way right it's not
just like let's [ __ ] on this person
because they don't know how to like
balance their books it's like oh wait a
second my finances look like that too
how do i actually learn from someone
who's more experienced and kind of help
me like walk through a lot of that so
yeah hopefully we can make that happen
yeah i'd be open to that it's just hard
with it with such a tight schedule
finding time to film and then getting
those shots i am so particular about
like yeah what's shown where getting all
the shots and then taking a day's worth
of footage and there's 15 minutes and
like that's the maybe 20. that's what i
get it it's funny
even
the reaction stuff because we're on the
other side of it where so many of our
videos are reacted to or mimics so good
for you yeah which is great yeah well
for a while there was like an internal
debate of like oh is this good you know
like we can monetize or we can claim it
if we want we actually don't do that for
a lot of videos because we're like you
know what we want them to like whatever
once it's on the internet it's no longer
ours only and if someone's mimicking our
content or like replicating it we're
like hey that's a good sign it means
that like we've built something great
but early on i don't know if you've ever
had anyone like kind of like mimic i'm
sure like copy your style yeah sure
right yeah like how do you deal with
that feeling when you see like clearly
they're yeah at this point you don't
it's become a a bit of a joke between us
now like an inside joke that uh
we predict certain
you know topics will come up and
usually it's like up jack right on
schedule yeah and you know yeah but you
know what uh
there's a good sign right it's not yeah
some sometimes it feels like because i
spent so much time on youtube
um it's really hard to find like topics
and things that do well
um
but you know at the end of the day it
just means that there's interest in that
so yeah that's but yeah what was it like
having pewdiepie react to your videos
dude that was insane it
i never thought
that someone of that magnitude let alone
the biggest youtuber would ever be
seeing let alone reacting to our content
so when that started happening it just
like blew up all of our socials like our
audience was growing and i think that's
when i started to realize there was a
shift in what was happening with jubilee
that we were no longer like a niche
channel that people may or may not have
heard of but now like it felt like
anyone who was spending any time on
youtube at least had seen one of our
shows
they may not know the name jubilee but
they've seen something that we've made
which was
insane you try to keep your persona
fairly incognito not that i
intentionally do it but i always knew
that if it was all about
me or jason it has to be in every video
that we would not be able to scale
so early on i was like okay it has to be
about jubilee or it has to be about the
show otherwise i'm gonna have to be on
every episode or i'm going to have to be
on every set and
we're not going to become a unicorn that
way we're not going to become a scalable
startup so when you ask me about like
hey are you over on set i'm rarely on
set now and i see it as like a wow
that's crazy but also that means that we
can do so much more so do you guys
because i know you you have had people
that are recurring in your episodes do
you try to build up certain
personalities within your company or not
really it wasn't like a strategic thing
of like oh jack he's a star we're gonna
make him a star um it's more when there
are folks that we just love both like as
a cast member like how working with them
but also how they show up and audience
resonates we like to bring them back i
think dating is actually a good example
of that like
we had uh a lot of folks who were like
eliminated early for whatever reason but
like there's they didn't get their time
to shine i like that they come back and
you're like oh this is the hero and
people recognize them they're like ah
finally just justice for jack you know
has there ever been a fight in like a
middle ground or a spectrum or something
like that where people like you know
this fight yeah luckily no you know
there have been episodes where honestly
we've been nervous we had an episode of
middle ground where we brought together
four or five different rival la gangs on
the set
and
you know we were not super familiar so
we had done a bunch of research but
we're like this could be really
difficult or
bad
and they were on set and they were
amazing and they had this incredible
conversation and they were like dapping
each other up and it was like okay wow
this is awesome and then there have been
other episodes with random
participants who get very competitive
like very difficult and we're like where
did this come from this was supposed to
be like a very easy episode um
so that's that's tricky because there's
like a lot of potential
um burden or like emotional trauma like
that can happen on set that we're like
very wary of so it's something that
we're like a lot more cognizant about
like do we need security ever like do we
need therapists like how do we even like
deal with some of these complicated
issues but luckily no no fights no
broken arms nothing
yeah probably should have one security
guard
now yeah no we we've got a security
guard for difficult issues yeah what is
like the big vision for for this podcast
where does this go into take it
mainstream that's the goal yeah we want
to get on people outside of like the
youtube space i want to get like
musicians yeah it's
you know pop stars and stuff like that
yeah i'd love to get all of those people
to talk about personal finance because i
feel like you know with musicians atom22
has such a good uh pulse on that to talk
to them but i feel like there needs to
be a financial component to that and uh
i really think we've got a great angle
on that it's still taboo like in the
mainstream media talk about people's
income from certain movies and stuff
like that uh and people theorize oh x
made 40 million off of this movie but to
actually hear them talk about their
competition for certain things or sports
stars kind of like the gq my first
million yeah but kind of to you know i
guess open up the conversation in the
mainstream media setting yeah like i
feel like a lot of people um behind the
scenes are great investors and really
savvy with their money but you don't
know them for that like shaq would be a
great example of like a really talented
business person but not everyone knows
him for that they'll know him for
basketball he's fantastic at basketball
but i feel like financially he's made
way more money from his investments and
his businesses so i feel like a lot of
people could be showcased in such a way
where it's an inspiration for people who
you know no matter what the background
is you could make it in business yeah
and not only that but they've got a lot
of experience with that so
those are things that i'd love to
showcase i love that i believe it so i
hope that becomes the case with them one
day i can be like hey i was i was one of
the first what 100 guests
well we've had some repeats i don't know
okay within the first two hundred in
there within the first thousand oh yeah
yeah
for that well thanks for having me so
much so much really really appreciate it
uh the one thing you got to get a free
stock down below one thing is
eric from tricaro oh yeah he gave us
this entire set like this is a lot of
his equipment it is
try carrot we'll link it down below give
out those metal credit cards really cool
if you're a creator influencer
definitely check it out are you pulling
yours out yeah yeah it's customized yeah
show up
i do not oh you need one use my referral
link
so
oh give them give them a little drop do
a little drop test
wow oh yeah wow i mean they don't mess
around with this heavy thing customized
for every creator they give us like
double cash
versus like the the reserve card yeah
wow it's a whole different level so i
love it so if you're a creator
influencer check them out with the link
down below in the description thank you
guys so much until next time until next
time cool i really like that